and I would sing blasphemies Against
Christ and I would try to make every
Christian doubt their faith because I
was Antichrist that's what these people
are they're Antichrist even the majority
of atheists who say oh I don't believe
in anything you look at their wall on
Facebook
mocking Christianity mocking Jesus oh
you know and you see it over and over
and over I'm like this is like me
posting
the Easter Bunny's not real and I can
prove it like why are you wasting time
on something that doesn't exist
[Music]
my uncle
okay so we're gonna be talking about
today about Satan Satan is ruling our
world have you guys heard uh Satan in
the news or in the movies and the music
industry is famous man Hollywood loves
the dough they make him look like a hero
yeah
right they may not say his name they may
not say Satan but there are many
synonyms out there sometimes they are
blatant about it though yeah that's true
you got a comic book hero named Hellboy
and Lucifer and all these things yeah
yeah we're gonna be talking about that
but before uh we're gonna go more in
details like you know you know new
movies or music and all stuff I really
want to like where where's Satan come
from you know because it was Lucifer
first right yeah he's a good guy yeah he
was a nice guy right I mean he was right
there next to God you know uh Library
you know protectings close to God and
everything but he wants to be just like
the Bible said you know he wants to be
like the most high you know he wants to
be putting his strong way up there in
the stars and not in a way like we want
to be like God he wants to take place of
God
yeah yeah so he was a Lucifer right the
uh the Morning Star right but also when
he commits sense he became Satan you
know Satan the adversary the the enemy
of the souls right I mean he has lots of
different names uh impossible or all
different names but interesting that
I mean you can go through the to the
Bible how Satan uh working and and
people's lives and things like that but
I just want to come back to
1969 66 how uh this guy uh until 11 you
know in 1969 I mean he started his
Satanic Bible right and he was very into
I mean can you imagine I mean somebody
thought that much that he decided like
oh you know what to date I mean I don't
know that he heard the voice or he's
like you know what I'm gonna be writing
how it's gonna be their fundamental
of Satanism wasn't his dad a preacher
though that was a good question I don't
know I never knew that either I believe
he was I gotta check that out I'm gonna
fact check me but um I would not be
surprised because it's probably how he
has so much Bible knowledge enough to
invert it because
from what I understand about the Satanic
Bible I've never read it but it's
basically a complete inversion
and these people like they would get
together and and sing hymnals in Reverse
like they would sing the words backwards
which gives it a whole different meaning
a lot of effort yeah well not you know
not like it does you know either way but
they're not saying the words backwards
they're saying the sentences backwards
oh yeah so if you say like God bless you
and be like you
bless God or something I don't know like
sometimes when you say word sentences
reverse it changes the whole meaning to
a reversal you know yeah yeah yeah yeah
for sure and let me tell you and The
Time Magazine and I believe he was in
This Time Magazine and the post right
there is the they took the time I mean
can you imagine I mean Time Magazine
took the time they have Oracle he said
and the earliest 1970s there was
interesting in their in their cult and
America culture it was so high that Time
Magazine devoted a cover story to the
topic and a large position of it was
focused on Satanism and the story
pointed out the idea of the devil wow so
it was too much you know the you know
people were talking or you know uh
groups and and let's take how about the
the I think it's called the the Church
of Satan right and uh so those guys say
you know what this is I think America is
growing
like before we don't talk about that you
know it wasn't taboo you know like hey
underground things and and I'm sure you
guys remember like I mean you guys know
you are alive but in the 80s it was so
famous about movies about Satanism you
know horror movies he was very popular
in the 80s time also highlighted
um the Christian Revolution right the
Jesus revolution in the um chosen video
that we made Keith really did a good
breakdown of Revolution versus Revival
and how Jesus came not to
um spark a Revolt
but to more have it to be a Revival so
it's interesting that in this context of
the occult they use the correct word of
Revival when it comes to Christianity
they say no it's a revolution it's a
Revolt it's like oh that's that's not
okay it is interesting because as
Christians we're the ones that are told
like this is devil under every Rock and
you guys just want to see the evil and
everything but this got
enough recognition that the secular
sources had to start talking about it
yeah I mean which is fine because
they're just commenting on society like
you know whatever to them but this is
just this this makes Satan look so
what's the word obsessed with God and it
also kind of shows how God is the one
with the blueprint because God what did
he do he inspired men to write his words
and now the Devil comes behind and
inspired until Anton Levy pronounce it
to to create the Satanic Bible so that's
not surprising to me that something like
that exists yeah it's like Satan cannot
have an original idea it's always like
what does God have I'm going to pervert
it exactly every time exactly yeah yeah
uh it isn't a very interesting song very
famous
The Devil Went Down to Georgia I
remember that I don't know if you guys
heard that one I have no idea what
you're talking about I think his belt
buckle says Jesus is Lord interesting oh
yeah so in 2013 let's come in or 10
years ago 10 years ago uh
remember in 1969 it was the Temple of
Satan or the Church of Satan right and
with Antonio
in 2013 10 years ago it was the satanic
temple and let me tell you there are two
different things you know a lot of
people is like oh yeah they're the same
guys or whatever but let me tell you
those guys they have like more
organize
system
of the charging everything like that
because let me tell you they said that
our religion doesn't believe in hitting
children
and they're like protecting the children
okay have a project they have a national
spoken
person for the satanic temple I don't
know if you saw this post before but
those guys they are protecting
the safety and hitting the children they
must be really nice guys yeah so is
there something in the Bible that says
to hit your children I mean maybe
stoning disobedient children where were
they even referencing here because
they're apparently taking a jab at the
Bible if they're saying our religion
doesn't believe in hitting children
probably ripping them out of the womb
I'm assuming they will stand for that
but yeah the difference is
Anton lavey's
uh Satanic Bible people think he's more
of a like a troll like this is we we
kind of it can be atheist you can be an
atheist and have the Satanic Bible
because
Satan's more like a mascot he believed
in Freedom and do what you want and
that's what we believe and they don't
really worship the Devils what they say
but the satanic temple
they have church services worshiping the
devil and they do their move they're an
active movement about getting
uh satanic books in schools and all that
yeah and we got to talk about that
because let me tell you I found out the
difference of the satanic temple of the
Church of Satan so in 2013 that was
officially recognized the other one is
not recognized I guess
uh officially recognized as a church but
they are IRS yeah exactly so it's more
like you know legal stuff or whatever
you can get a tax exempt there yeah yeah
interesting yeah so uh they believe you
know the actual Satan right both of them
uh the satanic temple they believe in
they don't believe in magic black magic
both of them supposedly don't believe in
Satan yeah that's what they say and and
the Church of Satan they believe
and the magic the black magic with the K
remember
and all those situations right and over
here in the other side you can see that
they have a regular meetings you know
like a normal Temple you know
and worshiping everything against Church
of Satan doesn't do that they have
activities you know public events and
all this stuff the Church of safety
doesn't have that what does this
believes that men who prefer blue cheese
dressing must be homosexually inclined
because of the odor is reminiscent of a
locker full of well-worn Jack straps
that they don't believe that it's truth
of Satan believe that so I have to I
have to change what I said because it
says belief in an actual Satan both of
them say they do not believe that but
the satanic temple is Super Active in
trying to bring satanic stuff
devil but they believe that all the
principles what the devil stands for is
what I'm thinking fundamentally
but it's like the uh Freemason
organization has levels it has degrees
and what you're exposed to is dependent
on what degree you're at is that the
same for the satanic temple because I'm
thinking if there's like a lower level
involvement they could just be living
their lives and have a lot of maybe even
the beliefs that we share
um it's not until they get higher up in
their organization that you know things
start to change and then they start
mocking other religions or what have you
you know what I mean like we can agree
with
we could agree with a Muslim on their
dietary uh standard right but we have a
difference in in like our spiritual
beliefs so could that be the same with
someone who is part of the satanic
temple where
okay we have the same standard of like
pro-life but in terms of who we serve
there's a difference there like is there
levels in the satanic temple are you
saying that the satanic temple is
pro-life
going go back to the previous slide
based off of the billboard like I'm
asking is this a job at Christianity is
this a job at the Bible or this is a
political statement they just happen to
be a part of the satanic temple I don't
know but maybe you don't know the
context of the poster but yeah but it's
very interesting
just like you know they're people yeah
they have families people who are just
antagonistic towards Christians and they
just know that this is gonna be the best
way because I was like this too man I
didn't believe in the devil or anything
but I was intrigued by witchcraft I went
down that road wore pentagrams black
funeral polish and and I would sing
blasphemies Against Christ and I would
try to make every Christian doubt their
faith because I was Antichrist that's
what these people are they're Antichrist
even the majority of atheists who say oh
I don't believe in anything you look at
their wall on Facebook
mocking Christianity mocking Jesus oh
you know and you see it over and over
and over I'm like this is like me
posting
the Easter Bunny's not real and I can
prove it like why are you wasting time
on something that doesn't exist so
they're really Antichrist and even I've
had I've brought that up to an atheist
and he goes well I'm more anti-theist
than atheist
um but what a reason I brought that up
was because
the ironic part is is no matter what
Drive no matter what's driving these
people if they're just doing it to jab
at Christians and we don't really
believe in the devil they're still doing
the devil's work yeah they're a pawn in
the game it's like I don't believe in
the devil at all I think it's ridiculous
but I want to put this Satanic Bible in
the school
you're working for the devil yeah I mean
if you're literally do you're you're
putting Satan's propaganda out there
even though you don't believe in them so
it could be the same in that they don't
believe in an actual devil but they're
adhering to those principles so when
they say they're Antichrist they may not
be anti the deity so to speak they're
anti the control that they think the
deity wants to have over us so it's like
um they want to do whatever they want to
do they may not necessarily be up for
child sacrifice type thing that's what
I'm asking for yeah like if there's
degrees to this so the last two I want
to focus on the Baphomet Monument so I
want to really pay attention the Church
of Satan I guess they don't believe that
or they don't worship or anything but
the satanic temple does and they have a
program let's go after school
Satan Club
so I'm going to talk about more about
that but I just wanted to let you know
that in 2015
and the city of Detroit they put a
bronze Monument was unveiled by the
satanic temple and that was the monument
what we see there I just want to ask you
guys what do we see there
on the Statue yeah in the Statue yeah we
have a uh amalgamation here where you
have both goat and human
two children are looking up to this goat
head
and has wings oh bathroom has wings yeah
does it okay first time I'm male and
female yeah I guess they don't put that
is that the uh
pharmacia yeah the
caduceus yeah so what I see is you know
a huge Monument right so goat and we
know you know that it's
Satan devil whatever you want to call it
but the thing is that you bring children
you know okay
that's another level that you put the
line and also what we see right now in
society all those you know people that
come to the schools and drag queens and
reading books and everything and they
even show us for children I mean that is
very disturbing so and so bring that new
show and uh Netflix uh there's a tiny
Temple because they were they were
filming that and they say you know what
uh you guys the
put in this bathroom in there and they
say you're not supposed to be put in
there and there are thing they asked for
oh let's suit them they suit them yeah
the satanic temple sued Netflix for
putting their statue in a negative light
do you know if they won
this is just b-roll behind them and they
yeah it's a problem they're like you're
a misrepresented well no it's it's a
real Statue it's not the statue right
it's a replica but in the movie they
didn't bring the statue to Hollywood
this is a b-roll yeah they made their
own oh they made their own replica Watts
they spent money and
it's like
wow yes this is Sabrina the Teenage
Witch that's an old show no that put
them in uh so is it done with Melissa
Joan Hart or no no
this went a long time maybe like three
or four years ago Sabrina Teenage Witch
was like the candy coat of Witchcraft
this is blatant Blasphemous open it's
called the chilling Adventures of
Sabrina's step by step witchcraft
telling you what to do and all those
sacraments I mean the first episode is
showing you how Sabrina become a witch
and they tell the whole thing what they
do in the woods I'll tell you what
though if Christians were to sue every
time Christianity was misrepresented
Hollywood would have to go bankrupt shut
it down it's ridiculous that's pretty
good so in 2016 okay seven years ago it
became a nice this show that nobody
really thought about I mean come on
Lucifer
oh this was so disturbing yeah it's your
first show right and they did uh I
believe it was five or six seasons about
it since 2016 2021 and I mean even
Christians that say Hey what is the
number one show that you watch on
Netflix Lucifer
I mean why you want to see I mean as a
Christian what do you guys think I mean
seriously uh to have a show and I really
want to see what
yeah what it's about like I want to see
what this guy is gonna be his character
or people are curious yeah
characteristic you know content is the
king like Curtis is really like maybe
the second one the Curiosity yeah
curiosity yeah a lot of times people ask
us to expose shows and we think oh
something that's you don't expect like
Lego Movie something like this you
wouldn't you wouldn't think needs an
expose but we actually have a video on
it because
Keith gathered some information that was
actually shocking to me it wasn't it
wasn't really details about the show it
was the fact that
they took the show down and people were
hashtagging save Lucifer and then there
was Christians that were wanting it to
come back yeah I mean a self-professed
Christian Kelly Clarkson was like I'll
pay for the next season to come back
that was what was shocking how many
people Christians were watching it wow
that was in 2016 right and the same year
the satanic temple
decided to say you know what let's start
this after school satanic club and this
is really this is then right now the
like CEO or the outspoken uh the satanic
temple and they said I said you know
what let's do that and I have a video
about it so you guys can learn oh
underneath all of this is a very
deliberate political motivation these
Satan clubs are trying to be provocative
they're not hiding that and they're
trying to use that as a scare tack
tactic to convince school boards School
administrators to not have any after
school clubs because if you have any of
them then you've got to also include the
Satan Club but it all boils down to
parental permission and just underline
that in your own mind when you see these
things for an after school club to work
in a public school the parents have to
give permission to it so what parent in
their right mind is going to give
permission to the Satan club that you're
going to learn how great Satan is uh no
it's not going to happen it's a scare
tactic let's recognize it for what it is
and in that don't back off don't say
well we're not going to have our Bible
club or we're not going to have other
after school clubs that parents will
want their children to go to uh just
because we want to keep the Satan Club
out you know prove it to us if you get
parents to sign up great if you can't
well then please go away the reality is
parents are The Gatekeepers
for all the clubs in schools because you
know what all of them need permission
slips signed by parents so parents hold
the power parents are the ones that
control the Satan clubs because if no
children sign up the Satan Club isn't
going to exist so is this still the case
because now we're hearing that lgbtq
discussions are happening in school
without the parents awareness or
approval so is this across the border is
this specifically for after schools
after school things or clubs I don't
think this is a during school event so
it probably needs probably needs
permission but if it's within school
hours then yeah wow
the I mean that's supposed to be
learning you know like you know science
they're going to be learning about you
know they have a nice nice beautiful
song
and look at what they the kids learning
about the sun okay
[Music]
it's a flyer with an eye-catching
statement hey kids let's have fun at
after school Satan Club the flyer tells
parents their child will learn about
benevolence and empathy critical
thinking problem solving hey kids let's
have fun at after school Satan Club a
lot of people have said is this a hoax
is this for real how can the Satan Club
even be
even realistic the state of Pennsylvania
recently rejected the club in its
schools while Satan clubs have popped up
in other states like Illinois and Ohio
it's the first time the idea has found
its way to North Carolina they say it's
a kid-friendly Club that's right hard to
believe but that's exactly what they
preach here and this is the parental
permission slip that they're handing out
so your kid can participate here's the
after school Satan website they even
have a children's book dedicated to this
now they say there are some wholesome
activities and lessons to be learned but
others believe it has no place around
children
foreign
[Music]
he'll always treat you equal whether
you're black white or King
all is said and done
Satan it doesn't actually exist
he's an imaginary friend who can teach
us how to live
[Music]
anyone creeped out okay so your thoughts
guys I mean the reason I'm trying to you
know bring this show to you guys and to
you guys to is the awareness you know
like maybe you didn't hear about this
thing I mean you have kids or anything
like that but people have kids I mean
they've gone to a public school I mean
be careful out there yeah you know and I
didn't know anything about it since last
weekend I was researching all the stuff
and I was like they have a song and you
know the power of music yeah you
memorize it yeah and what is really
disturbing you after you watch I mean
listen to this song the words so maybe
some words that you're like what
everything I I there's not one thing in
there that I wasn't like oh yeah that's
normal it was it was all creepy every
single part of it and the weird part was
it really didn't have a
chorus did it did it have a chorus I
mean the one thing they kept saying is
there is no hell yeah but um
it was weird yeah and six months ago I
mean they just decided like you know
what let's do this thing to bring it to
Virginia and it's coming to the church
yeah I mean it's schools and uh Mikey
you want to say something I was just
gonna say they they mentioned that Satan
it doesn't treat you different whether
you're black white or gay it's true he
hates you no matter what you are feeling
destroyed it he doesn't discriminate
um whereas God loves everyone and wants
to change your life and give you Freedom
over sin and
uh so they're making a whole club about
an imaginary friend who's not real but
these are the things he stands for it
just seems kind of that's helping to
find truth yeah that was weird because
when is God ever lied so what does this
pursuit of truth that he is searching
for one thing that bothers me is that
people think
Christians don't believe in science that
whole thing was like look we believe in
science and that's what bill and I had a
debate with the guy from Genesis Answers
in Genesis
yeah and and over and over like I
watched that whole debate and was very
disappointed there wasn't a lot more
debate going on it was like Ken Ham
would say something and then bill and I
would say you know it's really important
that we have scientists and I need all
these kids to become scientists and it's
like science is great Christians believe
in it his whole thing was like if you're
a Christian you're an imbecile you don't
believe in science and they just back
that same
stereotype up too you know some things
aren't worth researching yeah I'm gonna
say that and uh when we read scripture
and how God just blatantly says
stay away be set apart if I got that
permission slip in the mail for my kids
it's going in the shredder like that I
don't even need to research or see what
it's about find out there's a nice happy
song or anything like that or you know
yeah it
what the um news reporter said is so
true it's parents that I was going to
determine whether this is going to be
successful or not and even giving
space and time to a discussion and all
of that and making it bigger than it
should be is just as harmful and then
also like building curiosity and then we
see how an association uh lessens
discernment it lessens
[Music]
um
what's like
um it lessens towards something
desensitize exactly and so oh you know
maybe maybe it is a nice song or maybe
we should you know dissect it and maybe
you know hey there's truth right here
and kind of soften you to like you know
maybe maybe we should let them go ahead
and take part in it and after school I
remember it being a fun time I mean if
you associate after school with hey play
time and learning I remember learning
about Satan he was a nice guy
wow uh interesting so in 2019 let's jump
in on a year you know 2019 I remember
2016 started this Lucifer guy you know
series and Netflix very popular in
everything
but and now let's talk about uh
entertainment actors you know they talk
about this thing like hey thank you
Satan because he helped me with this and
getting all scars and you know stuff
like that and I have this clip from
Christian Bell thank you to that Geezer
over there Adam he said he said uh he
said I've got to find somebody who can
who can be absolutely charisma-free
and reviled by everybody so he went as
well we bail in it you know thank you
and uh for all the competition I will be
uh cornering the market on charisma-free
what do you think Mitch McConnell next
that could be good Nick
um
thank you to uh Satan for giving me
inspiration on how to play this role
so it's just you know he's receiving I
mean this a Golden Glove in our words
you know I mean it's not something like
hey you know you're in the street and
nobody gonna see you no he's in public
you know he's a huge receiving this
achievement you know to be the best
actor you know of the year but I thought
the Temple of Satan said that Satan
wasn't real yeah and there's always like
a nervous laughter that follows when
someone does it you think nervous
laughter is like oh is he being serious
or is he joking or no don't don't share
our secrets right yes you'd think they'd
just be like yeah that's right you know
if someone says thank you Jesus it's not
like
he just thank Jesus it's not a it's a
different response yeah that just shows
you that naturally this is not right if
somebody says thank you Jesus there's
either going to be Silence from some
people or Applause there's not going to
be like it just doesn't happen but when
somebody thinks Satan there is an
awkwardness and people laugh out of
they don't know what to how to react
fill the space yeah I mean it's just
like how do you react to that yeah and
in the same year also I mean uh Temple
it was like fighting for Religious
Freedom this is a I wouldn't call it a
gray area but we have to remember the
context in which we live this is the
United States so I would never fight to
remove there right to practice I mean
I'm saying practice hold on obviously
there's limitations when it comes to our
um
our rights as as individuals so when I
say freedom to practice if they're
harming someone else that's not okay but
just uh religious freedom because once
we take it away from them it's not going
to be too long until it's taken away
from us as Christians so we need to be
careful about that yeah yeah and I just
want to remind you guys that you know
it's a difference you know with the the
temple satanic temple and the Church of
Satan you know established 1966 uh it
was said in the you know those guys
before I mean it seems like they were
doing like a huge you know human
sacrifice you know you know drinking
blood or something like that but these
people supposedly I haven't been to
those you know masses or ceremonies of
the time uh the satanic temple but
they're supposed to be different and
they're fighting for their rights yeah I
mean they're right there in 2019 uh
they're outside and the Capitol Hill and
just asking for
literally for all
Christianity and Satanism yeah you know
I'm seeing people standing outside of
like government buildings and having
their stance and it's just reminding me
that you know there's voting in this
country and depending on
the votes that go in that determines our
legislation and so have you ever heard
someone say oh I'm not Christian I'm
spiritual yes so they they follow a lot
of Christian like principles and they
have that lifestyle but they don't want
that label on them of them being
Christian well think about that on the
flip side how many people live out
Satan's principles but they don't call
themselves satanists and they vote a
certain way and they push certain
agendas and
Society follows so it is interesting
that the Church of Satan might be a lot
bigger than just those who are in the
organization I think lebe actually says
that he says that this is how most
people live most of the time and I
that's a direct quote I think from
something he said I find it interesting
this guy's wearing a Disney character in
the form of Satan yeah all right yeah
just interesting kind of a good point of
what Anton lavez said this is what the
majority that's what that's what the
Bible teaches too the majority the broad
road is on the road to destruction the
road that's not gonna inherit
eternal life
so the majority of people and and he
says if you're not for me you're against
me
so in spiritual black and white Bible
terms
anyone who's not a Christian is
literally a Satanist I've never seen
this before religious liberty for all
and they have a Christian sign there too
because they're saying hey if you get
Freedom we get freedom because the
coexist bumper sticker yeah yeah for
sure well what about in 2020
we're gonna be learning more and let the
video to play themselves the
advertisement brings together Ryan
Reynolds Taylor Swift and Satan now in
the year 2020 personified as a malicious
woman it's an ad for match.com Gene
moose explains
Satan has the Hops
for 2020.
they're a match on match.com meeting up
in Central Park a bad guy and a bad year
hey
two zero two zero please
call me 20 20.
the web ad is the brainchild of actor
Ryan Reynolds and his Production Studio
so where are you from
oh
me too the devil is in the details from
the WTF in the end zone to Satan
refusing to enter a church to this
smitten couple taking selfies in front
of a dumpster fire
and the soundtrack Taylor Swift let her
friend Ryan Reynolds debut the
re-recorded version of her old song
[Music]
after losing her rights to the original
she's redoing some of them I've been
feeling so alone I keep waiting when
Satan hooks up with 2020 naturally they
steal toilet paper the web ad is getting
rave reviews
diabolically clever winner who gives out
awards for commercials because this one
fits 2020 perfectly it's actually
comical but what are they ever what's
the advertisement for is this just like
a uh like a government campaign ad or
something oh match it's matched up yeah
yeah that's that's right yeah so an
interesting bit people I mean you learn
a lot of things when people the comments
of the video the other one person who
said people love the Demonic commercial
better if it was Jesus there were lots
of their minds sick world that we're
living in should we do it should we do a
experiment a little light put out a
commercial yeah not soccer it is of
course with a good message and see how
it's
accepted.com Jesus he's a match for you
he wants to have a relationship with you
exactly yeah that'd be good and get sued
by match.com yeah because they don't
want Jesus or they want Satan I don't
know that's not saying that's true so
this is a play on the pandemic right
what happened in 22. yeah they're kind
of interesting like I said you know I
just select that video because I was
like oh you know I'm gonna say damn it
was not a big deal you know it's just a
character you know I mean in your mind
you know how our human Minds is like
thinking like you got that picture like
you know he's a cool guy you know
I mean you know you go to the gym oh
that's a love story yeah he's eating a
little you know paper or anything well
you know let's have a good time but let
me tell you 2021 show up 2017 and these
rappers say you know what I'm gonna make
a crazy
crazy
video
music video and I don't need to be
showing pictures and everything but you
we got a video up there and a little
assiduous how this guy is dancing I mean
he giving a dance uh lap dance a lap
dance to the devil I mean I mean who
come out with the idea and these guys
say you know what let's promote this I
don't know if he create his thing or he
somebody use this guy to promote this
tennis shoot but it's like you know the
Satan shoes you know with human blood
inside the exactly
what's going on and they were selling it
for how much Mikey
666. yeah oh yeah yeah it was a lot of
money and
um Miley Cyrus was rocking hers
really yeah it's sold out in very short
time yeah a few hours or something like
that yeah Luke 10 18 and he said unto
them I beheld Satan as Lightning falling
from heaven
yeah
so that's 20 21.
so what's going on in 2022
what's going on so let me tell you right
here and this day uh
Illinois okay
and I this is the Capitol Hill right and
they said that in December they say
let's bring this
um
uh I think it's called
chanuka oh Hanukkah Hanukkah okay
Hanukkah they celebrate that and I
believe this is a channel
is it different no that's not your home
because it's not C in it I know is that
a difference between no am I tripping
what what is this
yeah Happy Chinese I don't know I think
it was Hanukkah but but I hope one is
that they brought you know they
celebrated that and also you know for
Christians you know Christianity I mean
they brought you know the you know Mary
and Joseph and baby Jesus you know and
stuff like that but yeah it's just it's
the same thing by the way it's the same
thing just spelled differently that's
actually the more traditional spelling
okay so they have those you know
the representation yeah Nativity and
stuff like that right for for in
December because let me tell you that
even the satanic temple they brought
their decorations decoration yeah it's a
serpent with apples and maybe I don't
know what kind of Bible is that but uh
science textbook because remember yeah
so this is the they want to bring that
too also so this is just in uh last year
what do you think how it's gonna be in
five or ten more years I believe this is
uh this is actually gonna be swinging
back the other way because this is this
is amazing What's Happening Here how
we're going so far deep in here but
people are going to start fighting back
and I see that happening today yeah it's
it's happening so so it's interesting
because Daniel 11 40 says this at the
time of the end the King of the South
shall attack him and the King of the
North shall come against him like a
whirlwind with chariots Horsemen and
many ships he shall enter into the
countries overwhelm them and pass
through and it goes on and explains that
uh this King of the South and King of
the North that are fighting against each
other these two battle the King of the
North we understand is a religious
organization and uh the King of the
South is
there's many different interpretations
of this but one of them is an atheistic
mindset and so the king of North comes
back and and smashes it now the
religious system that is talking about
here isn't a good religious system so
it's fascinating to see what's going on
right now because I think we're going to
see a pendulum swing yeah well this is
like uh you think about the Spanish
Inquisition the Roman Empire and stuff
like that it was like they're killing
Christians throwing in the lines then
burn them at the stake and all that and
then it's like nope uh Battle of the
Pope or be burned to death like it swing
the other way like they supposedly
believe in the Bible you weren't allowed
to read it but the popes were saying
that we believe the Bible and if you
don't
then you get burned out of stake I mean
that was an extreme swing the other way
the famous phrase you know with the with
this with the knife you know then that
UFA you know you want to kiss that rain
you know or you're gonna die Marcy
interesting why do you think they need
to always depict the serpent in its
cursed State I know right yeah it
doesn't have it's in its cursed State
instead of pre-cursed there's cursed to
crawl on his belly so he either had legs
or wings or something I was just kind of
thinking about it because you know the
Nativity is like the the birth of Christ
you know so I was thinking about
satanics you know Satan what it was the
birth you know I mean okay maybe they
when the sin came to the world you know
they put the yeah
story here yeah kind of like hey you
want to tell the story again in 2023
here we go that's today
this year in 2023 remember when it
started the tempo satanic temple it was
in 2013. so 10 years later
the tiny Temple now it says you know
what now we are organization we have a
spoken person we can do after school and
we had this and we got that and now they
have convention but worldwide and it was
celebrating this year well it's going to
be a busy weekend hundreds of members of
the satanic temple will be in Boston
this weekend for a convention and as
wbc's Anna Miler tells us some are not
thrilled by that
the sold out event is starting today and
it's happening all weekend here at the
Marriott in Boston and a counter event
is planned in response people are
arriving in Boston from all over to
attend what's expected to be the largest
satanic gathering in history it's about
supporting human rights it's about
supporting women's bodily autonomy it's
about freedom of religion freedom from
religion the event marks the 10-year
anniversary for the satanic temple and
will include Satanic rituals
entertainment and discussion panels I
understand the confusion the fear I
really do but at the same time we're
very misunderstood group organizers are
dedicating Satan Khan to Boston mayor
Michelle Wu because the group was not
allowed to deliver a satanic invocation
at City Hall last year the mayor's
office says neither mayor Wu nor the
city of Boston are sponsoring or
affiliated with Satan Khan 2023 mayor Wu
will be out of town this weekend a truck
with a Christian Action Network
billboard is parked outside the Marriott
and a Christian event called revive
Boston is happening this weekend in
response Satan's a deceiver so anything
other than Jesus is not the truth so I
feel bad for these people organizers
with the satanic temple say they do not
believe in Satan but rather push for the
separation of church and state and that
their mission is to encourage empathy
among all most don't believe in Satan
not a literal Satan
um it's not it's not some 1980s horror
film I think it's a little odd but
they've been very hospitable to people a
woman staying at the Marriott for a
medical convention says she is relieved
she's heading home today I just think
that people's opinions are going to get
out of hand and
it's growing this you know the
Witchcraft and uh satanic temple
philosophy and all stuff why did that
logo why Satan if you don't believe in
Satan why not use like a DNA strand and
say we're human and we believe in human
rights and freedom freedom and all these
things like
we probably have a lot of similar
beliefs we believe in separation church
and state you shouldn't have the the
state ruling church and and saying you
know we we believe in Freedom we believe
in freedom of religion
but why use Satan as a mascot if you
don't believe in him believe in you
believe in science cool make your logo a
test tube I just don't understand you
know how do they not see that they're
being deceived by the devil I don't
think they know the scriptures I think
people are lost in lack of knowledge
and unless they are just hey I I could
care less about being here which I think
few are
most people just don't know they don't
know what they're doing I I truly
believe that yeah interesting forgive
them Father they know not what they do
they've been blinded by the God of this
world and yeah so I just want to mention
something that you know it's been
growing a lot uh I mean I
you know researching this thing and it's
like you know people making a million
dollar tarot cards reading business
why because it's a demand people you
know making I mean this thing about you
know uh you know occultism and
everything is growing very very fast in
2023 it's like huge and
what I'm going to focus right now is
about
how when you see things you know on TV
entertainment music repetition I mean
you will learn you know even
we make a video about this thing a
reaction video when these uh Billy Irish
no Irish
uh she did this
um because the video was revealing in
that time I mean you guys uh we need
some good girls good girls go to hell
and seriously about climate change yeah
and I mean she said that God is is is a
girl
and it's a lot of things in that my
Lucifer is lonely yeah I mean those are
her Ariana Grande no her too okay let me
tell you what happened if a children
watching this kind of stuff do you think
I'm gonna copy that absolutely
yeah that's what I was just thinking of
before right before you went to this
slide and you said the occult is growing
I was gonna say I blame Hollywood and
then boom here it is yeah
it's you know and
I have a video right now and when I see
these clips seriously that really
it hurts me because I'm a father and I
have two girls and I see how children's
just watching this
this kind of you know darkness and just
just make me so upset to watch this
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
another one
another one and one another one starts
to rise
your body on your body on your body
everywhere
so what do you think the children now
they observing this it's like nowhere
and now the parents I mean maybe the
girl maybe she doesn't know what's going
you see that I want to do this person's
like no what are you talking about I
mean you don't need to do that but no
the parents say no I'm gonna help you
I'm gonna do this it's a challenging how
fun and everything but let me tell you I
went to this
the girl has a YouTube channel and doing
all this stuff about these
you know singer and doing a lot of
things of duplicating
from uh like doing covers of people's
music yeah wow and I'm like wow shocking
and she is and I'm gonna play with you
guys I don't know if you wanna
share this team but I just want to share
how raw it can be a little kid
five years old go to this concert
really I just
lyrics up there I can't tell it's I'm a
bad guy yeah I mean I don't know the
looks of the song but that's what she
said at the end oh is it
so the sad part is is you know what if
these parents become a Christian and
they're and they've trained their
children to sing about Lucifer it's a
dress up like a fallen angel
like imagine the regret in their heart
when they're like we spent time money
effort to to do this like
I just can't imagine the type of regret
that we're feeling and and not only that
but there's multiple levels of deception
going on here because number one
Satan doesn't look like this right he
doesn't even look like he doesn't have
black wings he doesn't he doesn't
pretend to be something that looks
terrible it has blood coming from
whatever I mean he's a beautiful angel
and so now they're not only deceived
into pushing his message but they're
deceiving what he looks like this the
we must look really dumb to the rest of
the universe yep
nothing is nothing is inappropriate
anymore
absolutely nothing nothing when it comes
to sexuality nothing in terms of
Darkness like from birth here's it
here's all everything and you just kind
of figure it out I mean life in and of
itself is difficult and confusing as it
is and then you throw on all these
things that is premature for a child to
even understand talking about gender
talking about you know life these
different lifestyles
and so this is just this is amazing her
knowing the lyrics and screaming out the
lyrics but having absolutely no idea
what she's what she's saying and how
that's affecting her behavior and the
people who are in charge of her parents
are just like well here you go
supportive of it yeah I mean to me it's
just an insane how five six years old go
to those kind of concerts just to see
the the the the the CD cover like uh
Billy Irish I mean yeah she's like look
she's like yeah exactly like what's
going on and I just want to share with
you guys because I was like this is raw
and I need to be addressed like please
don't put this thing to the children
this is so sad the beautiful promise I'm
gonna end this if you if you like really
into about evil things or or you're not
in the church or you're not practicing
practicing Christianity the promises is
that in Proverbs 22 6 it says train up
your child in the way you should go and
when he is all he will not depart from
it okay man so I just want to end it
with this with this beautiful promise
you know it's not something like okay
you really
must stop in your ears or something like
that it's not hope for you but indeed is
Hope because Jesus and then the cross
for our sins and the great hope is that
he's coming back soon yeah I love that
verse because it says when he is old
he'll not depart from it it doesn't say
that they won't ever go astray you know
but if you never lay that Foundation
basically this road away from God it has
one one destination it's always going to
be death and destruction hopelessness
emptiness because we're all
God created us all with a vacuum for him
and so we're trying this makes me happy
for a season this makes me happy drugs
sex alcohol all these things they make
me feel good for a moment
but all those ultimately bring you to
hopelessness drugs you you become sober
again you have to do addiction all these
things
but what if someone was never trained up
they keep choosing all these paths
and now
I can't say they'll never find it
because thank God they're still
missionaries in churches and things like
that but when you train up a child
that's always going to be their
Foundation even if they stray away yeah
well I want to try this I want to try
that I want to try that once
everything's hopeless it's like
maybe my parents were right it worked
for them
maybe I'll give it a shot and then
they're ready and that's the way it was
for me my parents trained me up I went
way astray but when everything was
hopeless and empty I said you know what
I never really got gave God a chance I'm
gonna I'm gonna try this
and that's that's where I found the
truth so train up a child because you
got to give them a foundation to come
back to
man okay you guys I hope you enjoyed
this led live uh please uh share this
link with your friends and families and
I know they're gonna be blessed and also
uh support these this ministry look like
Studios to make more shows like this you
know thanks so much for your donation
check the the description on this video
with the links uh if you want to uh have
these nice shirts and ink in Spanish and
English and maybe to start a
conversation too you know uh these ones
we support and don't forget to like this
video because that helps to share this
video and all over the world thanks so
much and we'll see you bye
thank you
foreign
[Music]
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you